and
good morning uh it's a pleasure
to be able to present this morning
at this bio conference live virtual
conference my name is cinnamon bloss i
am a faculty member at the scripps
translational science institute
in la jolla california and this morning
i'll be uh having the pleasure to to
talk a bit about our work in direct to
consumer genomic testing
in just a couple of words before i get
started with some logistics items um
as they come to mind please submit your
questions to me while i'm speaking so
that i can address them at the end of my
presentation
and also
attendees can earn free ce credits
accredited by the ascls pace process
you can click on
bioconferencelive.com website homepage
and click on the ce credit link to find
the listing of my presentation and if
you
click on that link you'll be connected
to an ascls website where the
presentation can be evaluated and you'll
be able to receive your ce credit and a
certificate
all right
uh so just um as a kind of a way to of
getting started i'll just give you a
brief overview of what i'd like to talk
about today um first just
i'm sure many of you are very familiar
with direct-to-consumer genomic testing
but i'll first just
describe a little bit about it some of
the controversies um in this area
and then get into a little bit about
the
what are the impacts on consumers when
they receive this type of testing what
does the the data tell us what is the
evidence in this area
and then finally uh comment on
sort of regulatory issues in this space
how this information
if not direct to consumer how should it
be delivered to people
this type of genomic information
and then end with some future directions
all right so um
uh so this slide uh
i think kind of uh encapsulates some of
the issues in direct to consumer genomic
testing so we have a person here
who goes to his or her mailbox
presumably at
their home
pulls out their kind of genome report
and gets
some information back about their
genetic susceptibility to moderate
moderate paranoia
uh you know hoarding tendencies and so
forth
and then of course uh at the bottom
there's a triangle with an exclamation
point in it that says you are no longer
eligible for health insurance uh kind of
tapping into
um some of the uh you know sort of
noteworthy fears about uh this type of
testing and so you know i think i think
we can ask ourselves is this the genetic
risk testing of the future
um
or are we there now
is this the genetic risk testing of the
present
so
i think that's kind of a one of the
backdrops to what i'll be talking about
okay
so uh
many of you you may be very familiar
with direct to consumer testing but
essentially what we're talking about
here is that a few years ago starting
around 2007 a number of companies came
on the scene that started to leverage
findings from genome-wide association
studies
to start to offer personalized risk
assessments to people who were willing
to pay for such testing
and the way this was being offered was
directly to the consumer without the
involvement of a health care provider
and also being offered via
kind of internet commerce and so what
this slide shows is a screenshot from
one of the the very leading direct to
consumer companies 23 and me
you know sort of describing
their what they call their personal
genome service you know they say get to
know your dna all it takes is a little
bit of fit
and this kind of describes the process
you go online to their website you pay
money with your credit card they send
you uh you know a quote-unquote spit kit
in the mail you collect your own saliva
sample in the comfort of your own home
send it back to them and then some
number of weeks later you'll get an
email
that basically gives you information uh
about your you know susceptibility to
certain
diseases certain traits
certain you know the way in which
certain
medications or drugs may affect you
personally based on your genetic makeup
and so uh this is a become a very very
controversial uh practice um but
interestingly and also uh has received a
lot of attention in the in the lay press
and in fact in 2008
time magazine named the retail dna test
in particular siding 23 and these tests
as one of the the best inventions of
2008
and uh but you know as i as i kind of
alluded to this is this has been very
controversial
so um
you know certainly in scientific
literature we've seen many many many
opinion pieces and commentaries that
have uh you know kind of sharply
criticized this practice so genomic
profiles for disease risk because it's
predictive or premature
you know do you know kind of hinting at
consumer protection issues by asking do
you know what you're buying
also hinting at this issue that
potentially offering information like
this can can be harmful to people um and
that uh you know
perhaps because of this um you know it
should be offered in a different way
perhaps through a healthcare provider or
you know potentially not offered at all
um so these are some of the issues that
that have arisen
and so uh you know this is just to uh to
uh kind of even further underscore that
certainly in europe there have been you
know also
in some ways kind of in parallel into
the u.s uh discussions about
how to regulate this type of testing and
in some instances um
certain countries have taken an even
more conservative approach uh for
example
a number of years ago germany actually
banned
receiving testing directly to the
consumer and
in fact
mandated that it be provided
through through a healthcare
intermediary
okay so just to kind of make explicit
what are the arguments for and against
this type of testing
so
essentially um you know and i just want
to kind of touch on some of the
highlights here
people who are in favor of direct
consumer testing especially have an
argument around uh you know sort of
individual empowerment so
you know individuals having access to
their own personal genetic makeup their
own
disease susceptibilities you know may
enable them to essentially be a better
advocate for their own health care
to become more involved in their own
health care that perhaps this will
motivate people to make more helpful
lifestyle choices
and then also kind of a democratization
of dna kind of argument that people just
have a fundamental right to their own
personal information to information
about their own bodies
and on the other side of that
you know i think there are several
noteworthy
opposing arguments as well certainly a
primary one is this idea that this
information is delivered direct to
consumer to people who you know may not
have a good appreciation of the limits
of this type of information
also uh issues related to uh the
questionable
validity clinical validity and utility
of this information
um
also the expense and the potential for
the cost of this type of testing to
exacerbate existing health disparities
um you know the
around 2007 2008 um i think we saw
prices from some of the companies like
navigenex um that were you know charging
upwards of two thousand dollars for
their personal genome testing and that's
gone down quite a bit um you know over
the past year and a half um you know
they're
you know 23andme has had prices as low
as you know 150 to 200
but you know i think that there is there
is still kind of an expense um
argument to be made also uh
issues around how to communicate this
very complex information
um that's another another argument and
then also finally
people have been very concerned about
the potential for harmful impacts on
people
the potential for estimates of high risk
to induce anxiety or depression in
people
or
another uh common concern that's been
cited is
uh the potential for estimates of high
risk to then result in people seeking uh
additional and possibly unnecessary uh
you know clinical screening tests you
know more frequent mammograms more
frequent colonoscopies
and so on and so forth
but importantly i think uh you know
these are these are testable hypotheses
um
and you know it would be helpful to kind
of have a data-driven discussion about
some of these things and
this is this is what motivated our study
which which i'll be telling you about
today which is the scripts genomic
health initiative
so uh i think at this point it's sort of
useful to go to the literature and
get an idea of what has been uh
studied in this area um
uh what what do we know from data about
um you know some of the kind of pro and
con arguments and so um what i'm showing
here is a graph showing the cumulative
number of articles in the literature and
then that's on the y-axis then on the
x-axis
the year of publication
and these articles are related to
direct-to-consumer genomics
and
what you can see here is that you know
starting in about 2006 2007 when some of
these companies were opening their doors
there became a very sort of rapid
increase in the number of opinions and
commentaries and editorials that were
published about direct-to-consumer
genomics kind of
again underscoring some of the comments
i made earlier
um but then if we start to look at
different areas of actual empirical
research in this area um you know one
area that that people have published on
it um is kind of serving what you know
potential consumers um
what their attitudes and perceptions
might be towards this type of testing
there have been studies of
um you know focused on kind of social
networkers as a you know um group a
group of people that would be likely to
use direct-to-consumer genomics and so
on
but you can still see even even with
this type of research there hasn't been
you know all that much kind of published
or all that much to really kind of go on
um
there's another research where people
have
you know
tried to ascertain the size the
potential size of the direct-to-consumer
testing market what are the impacts of
certain um advertising campaigns on
direct-to-consumer genomics but again um
you know not not many articles even um
you know as we've made it to you know
the current period 2012.
and then finally um when we consider
studies that have actually tested people
uh and people who have actually
undergone genetic or genomic testing
received information back um and then uh
have tried to
uh sort of measure what their responses
were of those individuals behavioral
psychological
uh the extent to which they've engaged
in additional health screening
you know we see even fewer studies so
really uh you know there's a lot of work
i think that needs to be done in this
area to really have a solid data driven
discussion to inform some of these
questions
okay so a bit about our scripps genomic
health initiative this is a longitudinal
cohort study of adults
and we studied a commercially available
test around
2008-2009 this was the navigence health
compass
and our
goal was to
try to assess the impact of testing in
sort of three primary areas one was the
psychological impact
and so we operationalize this to mean
sort of anxiety changes in anxiety as a
result of testing
also the behavioral or lifestyle impact
we operationalize this to mean changes
in diet and exercise
and then finally any
impacts in the area of
engaging in health screening behaviors
we recruited individuals primarily from
health and technology companies
and we cast a pretty wide net in terms
of inclusion criteria
you had to be over 18 have a valid email
and be able to provide a co-payment and
just a couple of comments about this
the email address is crucial because all
of our study procedures were done online
which uh you know it's essentially to
kind of parallel the way that the direct
to consumer genomic testing environment
you know sort of works at this point
um also uh you know we did require a
co-payment for our study again to kind
of make it as sort of ecologically valid
as possible um but at the time uh the
test was was selling uh for about two
thousand dollars so there was a pretty
substantial discount
for participants in our study
okay and just a quick overview of
procedures um if you know we we sent out
several sort of recruitment emails to
various companies people would come to
the landing page for the study
complete an online consent
submit their payment information and
then complete a baseline health
assessment that essentially
had items that tapped into those three
main domains that i mentioned previously
then they received back their personal
genome report from navigenex which i'll
describe in a moment
and then uh 90 days following the
receipt of that report
individuals were prompted to complete a
follow-up health assessment
and then um and then another 12 months
following completion or following
receipt of
their report they were asked to complete
another assessment
okay so uh many of you may be familiar
with
sort of what or many of you may have
even undergone testing with with one or
more of the companies that offer this
but uh this is essentially kind of the
main page of what you um of what
participants see when they had when they
entered when they underwent testing with
navigates at that time
um
at the time of our study uh when it at
the outset of it uh navigenex was
offering risk assessments for a total of
23 conditions and they're listed here on
the left
during the study they actually
added five new conditions to their
reporting
and so we've actually done some
subsequent analyses to try to
parse out uh what were the impacts of
adding those five conditions
but just and i'm sure this is very
difficult to read so i'll just kind of
just describe the report but basically
um people get information about back
about not only their um
their specific risk for each of the
conditions but they also see right under
that
uh the average population risk for
people of the same gender
um so they they kind of have a an
immediate snapshot of you know sort of
how their risk based on genetics
compares to the average person
okay so um
we
uh we
uh in early 2011 we published our
initial study on this project
where we looked at uh
changes in the three areas i mentioned
and um essentially and we kind of kind
of turned this our short-term follow-up
assessment
and essentially we found
no association
um no changes in anxiety diet or
exercise between baseline and follow-up
short-term follow-up and also
no associations with sort of the
magnitude of the risk estimates that
were disclosed either
and importantly we also didn't see any
association with
you know sort of increases in actual
screening test completion
but we did
in addition to kind of assessing actual
behaviors we also asked people
okay you know it's been um you know
three to six months since you received
this test uh you may not have had time
to see your provider or request
additional screening do you intend to do
this in the future and we did see some
uh
uh reports from participants that in
fact um they had they they standed an
intention to complete screening in the
future
um
uh but and in fact the these reports
were in fact associated with the risk
estimates that were disclosed but
um
uh
but it begs the question what do we see
at long-term follow-up do we see any
participants actually following through
on this and
increasing their screening test
completion
okay so i'm going to talk a bit about
our long-term follow-up data which are
currently
we have a manuscript describing some of
these results that's currently under
review
our long-term follow-up cohort
is
about 2 200 individuals which is a 62
follow-up rate overall
um slightly
predominantly female
people there's a quite a wide age range
in our cohort ages 19 to 85
with the mean age being about in the mid
40s
also uh real importantly um to kind of
talk about some of the unique um sort of
attributes of this sample um this is a
on average uh people with you know quite
a high income certainly much higher than
than what we see on average
and also
these individuals tended to be quite
highly educated as well so
um certainly we wouldn't we wouldn't say
that these are representative of like
the general population but um we did
explore sort of the overlap in the
demographics of our cohort with um the
navigenex consumer base and did did find
that there was quite a concordance
between
um
uh you know our cohort and their
consumer base suggesting that our cohort
probably was representative of current
navigenetics consumers
our cohort is also predominantly a
self-reported european
and the data that i'm going to be
showing you are based on a follow-up a
mean of about 14 months post-testing
okay so um this table here shows our
outcome measure
the baseline short-term follow-up and
long-term follow-up
means for each of the outcomes the
average difference and then the p-value
and what you can see here you know draw
your attention mostly to the p-value
column on the right
you know we see results that are you
know generally very consistent with
short-term follow-up no changes in
anxiety
we are seeing a
statistically significant reduction in
test-related distress which uh asks
questions about the experience of
getting their test results specifically
and it's not surprising that that has
gone down since it's been you know a
longer time period since they received
their results
no changes in diet
based on our measures um which were
self-report no no changes in exercise we
do see an increase in um
sort of the
raw number of screening tests completed
and even that you know in a period of 14
months you know we would sort of expect
people um to
you know naturally go to their position
complete certain um screening tests just
as the course of natural or of um
you know standard of care
so um
initially we didn't make too much of
this but um but it did uh prompt us to
conduct some further analyses which i'll
show now
and also importantly we didn't see we
also conducted these analyses looking at
the extent to which
changes may be
sort of associated with the specific
genetic risk estimates disclosed and
didn't see any effect there
either
so
one thing
one other way that we kind of pursued
this uh analysis is that we actually
assessed which patient or which
participants spontaneously shared their
results with their physician especially
since there's such a controversy in this
field about
whether a physician or other type of
healthcare provider should be involved
in this process
and
what we saw here was interesting
that
people who shared with their physician
were more likely to engage in a greater
number of screening tests um after
genomic testing yeah which in a way
isn't really that surprising uh but um
you know it was interesting nonetheless
we saw some other significant
associations with physician sharing but
tended to focus on this increase in
screening um
especially given that there was kind of
an overall increase in screening as i
described in the previous slide
and this is based on our full cohort of
20 about 2200 individuals
um so
we wanted to delve a bit deeper into
this and actually look to see
if sort of patterns of
the association between physician
sharing and screening was associated
with
specific screening tests and specific
disease risks so the way that we
conducted this was that we we actually
assessed a total of 13 screening tests
um including a
glucose assessment
mammogram self-breast exam
psa testing
and several others an eye exam
and what we did was we paired um each
screening test with the appropriate
condition that was on the navigence
health compass
and
looked at association between
physicians sharing the genetic risk
estimates that were disclosed
and the extent to which
these variables
led to an increase in the completion of
screening for that particular test
and what you can see here is that it's
it's uh
sort of i'll identify the overall trends
because
obviously it's difficult to parse each
individual line but these these are
plots showing the odds ratio for each
effect in a logistic of individual
logistic regression models um asking the
question about the likelihood of
completing an individual screening test
and so for instance the the the
particular lines that i've highlighted
here
have evaluated the extent to which
physician sharing genetic risk for
age-related macular degeneration
whether those variables or the
interaction between those variables is
actually associated with
the completion of
an eye exam
and
what you can see is that overall uh
physician sharing was you know
generally for almost every screening
test and condition pair that we
evaluated physician sharing was
associated with completion of screening
genetic risk did not motivate from these
analyses
screening test completion
for a small number of
screening test condition pairs we did
see an interaction with people who had
higher risk and who shared were more
even more likely to complete the
screening test but i think the general
message from this analysis was that um
you know we saw this
this effect of physician sharing uh
being associated with uh likelihood of
screening test completion
we also asked people about their
perceptions of the test uh the extent to
which they they thought the test was
useful
um especially given you know that
there's kind of been this controversy
around you know what what is the utility
of this testing
um
so uh
in this cohort um which i think is
probably going to be sort of the best
case scenario because these people
all signed up for the test they they all
you know kind of agree to to undergo
testing
um
uh and uh so they're going to be kind of
most primed i think to to believe that
the test is useful um and so what we're
seeing here is that you know just over
maybe about 65 percent of the cohort
said yes um it's it's certainly useful
uh another you know 35 to 40 are saying
it's somewhat useful
we also ask people you know to what
extent do you understand your feeling
feel that you understand your results
most people maybe about 70 or so said
yes
then another pretty substantial fraction
said yes somewhat
i haven't shown the data here but we
also asked people um to what extent do
your genomic test results do you find
them to be kind of generally consistent
with what you previously knew about your
health like your family history or you
know your personal health history what
conditions you may already have
and i haven't shown these data but for
the most part people
were
saying that it was generally consistent
with their previous health history
so uh in throughout our uh the period
where we were studying this with
navigenex they also released their
pharmacogenomic testing panel
and this allowed us to add uh another
arm of the project where we evaluated
essentially a number of the same
outcomes with respect to a subset of our
sample who underwent pharmacogenomic
testing
and these are sort of some preliminary
data we're still in the process of
looking at some of these results but
just to briefly describe the
navigenetics test
that's at the point at which we were
studying this they were offering results
for 12 specific
drugs
some of which were
giving results back related to the
likelihood of experience a side effect
some just about the likelihood of that
person to respond to that drug on the
basis of their personal genetics
and so here's some some very preliminary
data from our study
and so we asked some similar questions
you know to what extent do you
understand your medications testing your
pharmacogenomics results and you know
again we're seeing a pretty high
percentage of the people who received
results saying
yes i i understand seven percent saying
yes i understand my results 22 standing
somewhat
we also asked do you plan to consult a
provider about your medication testing
and
this was interesting because
um you know very few people said
unequivocally that they did
55 said you know maybe possibly in the
future and then 42 said no i think to
some extent these results probably
reflect um the very uh you know the wide
age range of our sample
the fact that um most people who
participated in the study were
relatively healthy and you know were not
on these medications
um but what's also interesting i think
is the last column where we asked you
know are these medications results
useful to you and um even though uh
only two percent said they plan to
consult a provider about the medications
you know almost 60 percent are saying
that the results are useful to them
uh so uh sort of an interesting and
interesting uh finding there i think
okay so i think um
some other areas where uh
we are kind of
kind of questions that have come up
about uh this type of testing areas
for further research um
are i think uh what are the impacts of
direct to consumer testing on families
and so here i'm actually showing the
results for my carrier status screenings
from 23andme
and
what you can see here is that uh you
know
um i do carry one of the variants for
hemochromatosis
and so this is interesting because i got
an email um learned of these results you
know over email um
and uh you know i wouldn't have really
thought too much about it uh i don't
have hemochromatosis so i wasn't too
concerned about it
but uh you know then i thought a little
bit more about it and um realized that
you know this could affect my son and so
you know i immediately had a
conversation with my husband about this
um turned out he didn't carry the
variance so we're sort of in the clear
but i think um you know if if we're
having this type of interaction about
receiving these types of results it's
likely that other families are having um
this type of interaction as well and
uh you know i think um
this would be an area kind of for
further exploration
and i think
this kind of provides a segue as well
into
what are issues around
you know testing for instance um miners
direct-to-consumer testing is miners
and so you know if if uh you know uh the
it appears that the direct consumer
genomics is controversial
in adults um you could imagine that if
you start to consider this type of
testing with kids it becomes even more
controversial so you can see here a few
of the commentaries that have come out
um you know
asking are the kids really all right uh
save the children direct to consumer
testing of children is premature even
for research
but the issue is that some companies are
already offering testing of minors
they with parental permission and so
i think this is an important
question to consider
and also i think this is important in
light of other evidence that's emerged
for instance from the multiplex
initiative which is another
large-scale study that's come out of
nhgri
where an arm of that study actually
conducted a survey of adults who
underwent direct to consumer genomic
testing
and asked those
individuals who had kids would you want
the genetic test for your children as
well and a majority of them said yes
we we do want to be able to have testing
done with our children
and it's possible too i mean the
argument has been made that you know
earlier if to the extent to which that
we can um
uh you know imagine that genomic testing
may motivate adoption of you know
healthier habits better diet more
exercise
if we can expect that it may be the case
that using this type of intervention
earlier in life um may be a better time
to try to uh you know sort of um
motivate adoption of these behaviors
before they get sort of uh
before people kind of get stuck in their
ways
as adults
and so um because of interest in this
area we actually conducted a small pilot
study here at scripps with a local
group of
high schools
where we did a kind of an educational
session with a group of 11th grade
students about 100 students where we
talked about personal genomic testing
and
show
them some of the reports
that are provided and got sort of some
information about their views on this
type of testing and whether or not they
should have access to it
and so they were shown
a drug response report from pathway
genomics they're similar to the
napogenics pharmacogenomics report they
were also shown one of the disease risk
reports from the navigence health
compass and i just included some of the
quotes from the students here
because we're still working on analysis
of these data but i thought the quotes
may be interesting to see so one student
said knowing this information early on
you're very well prepared later in life
to know how to take care of your health
okay
another student says i think it should
be available i think someone my age
would have the ability to not overreact
and if they didn't understand it they
would know how to get further
information
another student said
and they were talking about the
difference between the disease risk and
the pharmacogenomics report the student
said
you should be able to receive the one
with disease risk because it's easier to
understand but you shouldn't be able to
receive the drug one without a doctor
because they could explain it to you
better
so uh just
some some anecdotal thoughts on on this
particular issue
and so uh
you know what about policy making and
regulation in this space
um you know many of you may be aware
that a couple of years ago there was
quite quite a controversial issue came
up when um one of the
main direct-to-consumer companies
pathway genomics um sort of initiated
a contract with walgreens to actually
sell their genomic cuts on the shelf at
walgreens
you know upwards of six thousand stores
throughout the u.s
and i think this sort of marked the
first time that uh this type of testing
went from sort of the internet commerce
space to you know being sort of on the
shelf
being sold in a retail fashion
and you know at this point uh there's
quite a bit of new york times coverage
the fda stepped in
um you know
asked for
pathway genomics as well as from another
a number of other companies you know
evidence that uh their test did not
require um federal regulatory approval
or if it did require approval that um
that that process should be initiated
and then
this led to sort of a cascade of events
um
in uh
there were there was a congressional
hearing
in which
there
were results from the gao where they
produced evidence of you know sort of
deceptive marketing practices and so on
and so forth from these companies so it
was a it was a difficult time for the
companies and sort of exposed some of
the issues
and uh in march of 2011 in fact um one
of the advisory committees to the fda
actually held um
a sort of a hearing on um to hear some
of the evidence about direct to consumer
testing and we presented some of our
results at that meeting um there were a
number of other groups there as well the
nhgri multi represented from the nhgri
multiplex initiative
you know where they sort of heard um the
evidence that existed to date
about this type of testing
and um
you know i think
there was
virtually no evidence that presented at
that meeting that that uh that um you
know sort of obviously suggested
um adverse events of direct-to-consumer
testing
but
uh still that committee um
you know i think essentially came away
with the idea that probably
direct-to-consumer testing should be
done through a physician and so
um i think those discussions are still
underway um policies or policy-making is
still ongoing
but it's
kind of an interesting area to sort of
watch
but this notion of
requiring a healthcare intermediary is
also one that i think deserves um uh you
know significant attention
um there's been a lot of discussion
about whether or not uh physicians are
sort of as a group are sort of the right
group um to be the ones to sort of
be the translators of this information
for patients for consumers
and an interesting uh survey was
published uh by medco a couple of years
ago where they surveyed over 10 000
physicians and
interestingly they found that um you
know 98 of physicians said that they
didn't doubt that genomics does
influence uh drug response for instance
so pharmacogenomics
but uh strikingly only one out of ten
reported that they thought they had
adequate knowledge of pharmacogenomics
to actually utilize that information in
their practice so
you know and a lot of other things have
been written about this particular issue
sort of uh really questioning the extent
to which um
your physicians as a group have the
uh
sort of enough training at this point in
time
um
to to be the identified translators
and so if not physicians i mean one can
ask the question well who who should be
the translators and so an obvious group
to consider are certainly the genetic
counselors uh one issue there is just
the lack of there's such a small number
of genetic counselors in the us um you
know less than three thousand in fact um
which is one uh per 135 000 people in
the us so with the dramatically
increasing availability of genomic
information
um
uh
it just seems um you know sort of
untenable to uh to to the idea that a
genetic counselor would be involved
or even a medical geneticist since there
are very few of those professionals as
well
that would have to be involved in every
single kind of clinical
issue centered around genomics
and in addition i think uh you know
there may be concerns about um the
extent to which patients consumers may
want physician involvement
these are some additional data from our
sdhi study where we actually asked
people
at baseline
what are their concerns about undergoing
testing and so we went back to look at
these kind of attitudinal vari variables
as a function of people who shared
versus didn't share their results with
their physician
and what you can see here is that
people who did not share their
information
we're much more like we're more likely
to say that they had concerns about the
privacy of their information
um
kind of raising the question i mean it's
not a dramatic effect but it sort of i
think raises the question that um some
people
may not want to share their information
with their physician due to privacy or
other types of concerns
so mandating that a physician is
involved
you know could could have additional
issues
as well
um so
in conclusion i think um from our study
uh you know we didn't really see any
measured adverse impacts of direct
consumer genomic testing although uh you
know these are very very early studies i
think you know there's a lot a lot more
work that needs to be done in this area
to really drill down on on some of these
issues um
well with that said i think our work is
sort of consistent with ongoing direct
access by consumers um
but uh you know i think
some
regulatory efforts around marketing
around um
making sure that consumers understand
the limitations of the risk estimates
that are provided
um
possibly some regulations around um
you know sort of consistency of the
approach between different companies
may be warranted
um
we also because of sort of this delivery
gap that i talked about there's evidence
suggesting that there and also um
the evidence suggesting that perhaps
people who shared with their physician
may be more likely to engage in behavior
change that you know potentially there's
a very important role for physicians and
possibly other providers uh sort of in
this process of directive consumer
testing
but um i think you know for that to
really um
sort of resonate um i think there's a
real need for greater positioning
education about genomics
to kind of close this delivery gap
and just once again i would just say
that
there's really a strong need for
additional research um
our studies i think have provided some
initial insights into this area but have
also raised new questions
so
i look forward to seeing
new work in this space
and just want to acknowledge my
my
collaborators and also
the funding agencies for this work
thank you very much
and i'll take questions now
okay
i apologize it took me a minute to find
the questions
um
please just bear with me a moment while
i try to read some of them
okay so i see one question here
and i'll just read the question briefly
speaking about direct to consumer from a
regulation perspective the bottleneck is
the lack of proper certification for the
technology being used
it is only recently that illumina
i guess they have applied for fda
approval of their sequencers
um
so uh
certainly there's
there's a lot going on in the regulatory
space
around um sort of a certification um
for the different aspects of sort of the
testing pipeline
the sequencers
the analysis algorithms the reports
themselves um and in fact uh
23andme applied to the fda i believe
just a month or so ago
um to get uh certain aspects of their
tests
uh approved um through through the fda
so um
i'm not certain uh what the question is
here but i would say that i think that
there's a lot that's going on in this
space and i think um you know it'll be
interesting in the coming months to see
how the fda responds um especially to
23andme's application
um
uh you know i think it's it's it's hard
to uh
imagine that there they would you know
sort of be shut down or something like
that
but i do think that this primary
question about the extent to which a
physician or some other provider needs
to be involved in testing will be sort
of a primary issue
okay um there's another question here um
so these tests may continue to evolve in
depth and quantity driven by the
underlying technology how do you see the
accurate accuracy of the current direct
consumer vendors
so uh yeah that's a really important
question sort of um i think there's a
couple questions in there you know i
often think about sort of the
reliability of the testing and sort of
the you know the classically termed
clinical validity of the testing
um and so you know as many of you know
there was a paper published in 2009 uh
in nature that actually looked at
concordance between
uh you know multiple uh testing
companies and you know with the same dna
sample
and although the actual genotypes
produced by the companies
agreed you know more than i think it was
99 they were very kind of the actual
genotypes themselves were very reliable
but
um the algorithms that were used to
derive disease risk from those genotypes
um did differ for i want to say maybe
half the conditions
um and uh you know i think uh
this doesn't necessarily stem from the
idea that you know one or another
of the algorithms is wrong really it's
more it was more driven by sort of the
criteria that different companies used
in determining which markers or which
snips they would actually include in
their risk algorithm so
um you know different companies have
different sort of standard statistical
standards um
sort of by which they'll they'll sort of
include a particular marker in their
risk assessment
and
uh you know it's a it's a difficult
thing to do um to to try to come up with
those algorithms
i don't
i i don't know to what extent there
there may be effort to sort of
make
that particular piece of it consistent
among the different companies
or if we really know which company
uh produces estimates that are
necessarily more clinically valid i
think we would need
very large longitudinal studies to
really to really uh
know whether that was the case or not
we actually did do an offshoot study of
the sghi
where we looked at the extent to which
the risk estimates provided were
associated with people's
reports of what their family history was
and what their own personal history of
disease was and
um we actually found that uh
you know um
there were significant statistically
significant associations suggesting um
you know that that that on some level
the test was kind of um you know giving
information that was consistent with
people's backgrounds but
um you know the effects were quite small
and so hopefully i see another question
here that says any info on the
reliability and quality of this testing
so i hope that that the answer i just
gave
will hopefully get at that question as
well
okay so i'm seeing another question here
people can hurt themselves with many
types of information
many of which have remained unregulated
so how is genetic information different
than say someone's credit report i think
that's a great question um for the
extent to which information can be
harmful especially if it gets in you
know into the wrong hands
um
so i think uh
yeah and into to the extent that that um
you know i think that there could be i
think what what
what
possibly this question the crux of it
kind of gets that is the issue of um you
know sort of discrimination based on
genetic information and
you know it's certainly the case that
uh genetic discrimination laws um have
have not been able to kind of keep pace
with you know the the rapidly advancing
technology and the event the wide
availability of genetic information
um
but you know there there is the gina
legislation um certain states have
passed legislation that uh it is
actually even more protective of
people's kind of genetic privacy and
anti-discrimination laws
california for example has extended
the state-specific
kind of geno laws in several ways
um
so i think uh
you know um
people
to kind of answer this question i mean i
think i think that's going to be one of
the main issues making ensuring adequate
anti-discrimination laws
and you know ensuring that people kind
of have control over their own
information
you know i think there's a lot of
concern now in the field about data
security
but also
you know we have this issue around
security of data but but also
the idea that it needs to be more widely
available so for instance maybe getting
a bit off topic but
um you know how do we get genomic
information into the medical records so
that it can actually be used by
physicians um
and so i think there's there's kind of a
tension there at this point in time but
um you know i do see see that those
issues will be worked out eventually so
i hope that that answered the question
um i see another question here asking
will the dtc genomics work on my cat um
i don't know if this person's asking
about their pet uh you know that's an
interesting question um
i have heard of people getting their
pets tested uh but i i would say that
that's sort of outside of my expertise
at this point so
uh
good question
you